what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
I'll be honest I love seeing girls
reactions to cliffhangers I love seeing
how you guys react to things because you
all usually freak out you all usually
like no but if you thought the
cliffhangers that I left you on so far
we're bad wait till we get to the end of
this video give this clip anger is not
so here's the deal if you're just now
joining us with secret Empire there have
been a couple of things that are
happened so far the long and short of
this is that the Cosmic Cube that was
used to basically alter Steve Rogers
memories to make him into a Hydra agent
to basically alter his past the
fragments have been redistributed and
just split throughout the rest of the
world and no one really knows exactly
where they are at this point it is Tony
Stark's rebel team and Captain America's
Hydra team trying to track down these
fragments now of course they have
different motivations as to why Captain
America wants to track down the
fragments and basically restore the
Cosmic Cube so we can alter all of
reality and basically recreate the
universe in the image of Hydra Tony
Stark wants to go through and use the
Cosmic Cube to basically fix everything
and undo hydras rule so it's pretty
simple in terms of how it unfolds but
what we end up doing here is we again
pick up with the vanishing point now
remember the vanishing point is a story
that we don't know anything about we
have no idea what this is all we know is
that it's just someplace that we just
picked up with at some point alone line
but what threw everybody off is that
where the entire run of all-new
all-different marvel basically told us
that Steve Rogers Captain America as we
traditionally think of him had his
history altered to make him a Hydra
agent the vanishing point gave us the
correct Steve Rogers the classic Steve
Rogers and so the idea seems to be
hinting here from Marvel that the Hydra
Captain America is not the real Captain
America now how this consolidates and
how this comes together we don't
entirely know and the reason why this is
so significant and the reason why it
raises more questions is because I he's
making his way through this vanishing
point classic Captain America as we're
going to call him is basically met by
the arrival of a couple of folks now
these foes are not significant it's
Batroc the leaper and the people are
really some of his most notable notable
enemies over the course of his
publication history but he suddenly met
with the arrival of Bucky Barnes the
Winter Soldier and Sam Wilson now this
is huge because Bucky Barnes was
basically killed by Captain Amir
which led to you know a lot of events
that are taking place in terms of the
dropping of the Thunderbolts and so on
and so forth
Sam Wilson is still alive but so the
question is what version of Sam Wilson
is this all we know is that we now have
these three characters this is kind of
cool because remember historically
speaking when it comes to Marvel Comics
this is the trifecta of the Captain
America landscape you have Steve Rogers
you have the sidekick Falcon and you
have Bucky Barnes all three of these
guys have at some point over the course
of their life been Captain America
that's the uniting factor between the
three of them classic Steve Rogers
classic Captain America was Captain
America for years and years and years in
his thundering outside ah you know of
course Sam Wilson was Captain America
and all-new all-different marvel and
Bucky Barnes became Captain America
following the death of Steve Rogers
after Civil War was over the first Civil
War event so all these guys have been
Captain America somewhere over the
course of their life now at this point
we switch over to the tosh.0 manof now
this is not a great big huge thing this
is Black Widow is a small little segment
here but this is basically the idea that
remember Black Widow is a tried and true
assassin spy whatever you want to call
her she's a jack-of-all-trades and
probably one of the most dangerous
people in existence the issue here is
that the champions team the team of
teenage superheroes who broke away from
the traditional Avengers before secret
Empire started basically joined forces
with Natasha Romanoff for the purpose of
learning how to become as good as she is
the issue with this is they got into it
not knowing what they were getting into
Natasha Romanoff does not play with any
kind of interrogation or anything like
that if you have information she needs
and you're a bad guy she will torture
you or she will kill you she'll do
whatever she has to do in order to get
that info the champions are not really
used to that remember the Charter of the
champions was instigated under the idea
that they basically wanted to help
people where the Avengers showed up into
cities and the Avengers fought bad guys
and then just walked away and said well
you know the government will clean it up
the champions idea was we have to fight
the bad guys but do we also have to make
sure that people are able to get back up
on their feet if their homes were
destroyed or something along those lines
and so they basically wanted to fulfill
the entire role now what this does is it
basically begins to pick up after the
events of our last video when we had
Captain America's team and Tony Stark's
team trying to track down the fragments
of the Cosmic Cube and this ultimately
need them to Ultron now this is kind of
a cool thing because remember this all
really goes back to the rage of Ultron
story and if you're not familiar with
that which we have not covered it comic
story uncover that rage of Ultron was
basically a story that was out of time
Marvel released it and then didn't tell
us when it happened what they did is
with all-new all-different marvel they
rolled that over and put it in
continuity meaning they actually gave it
a time frame but what rage of ultron
basically established was the idea that
Ultron had effectively returned Ultron
was back and he created like these robot
versions of the Avengers and different
things like that but the idea was that
the story concluded with hate Pam and
Ultron being merged into the same being
and it made sense because Hank him was
the creator of Ultron and the two have
always had this sort of unique situation
I very much father and son kind of
relationship with each other but it was
only a matter of time before we saw that
kind of an event take place now
following that Ultron appeared a couple
more times
eventually he showed up in all-new
all-different marvel he fought against
the Avengers unity squad which was
Captain America leading like Deadpool
basically a combination of mutants and
Inhumans working together but the idea
was that following that event ultron had
basically just kind of been you know
shot out into space or something along
those lines and then we never really
knew what happened to him
what just does is it picks up all the
wings the uncanny Avengers story and it
tells us that at some point somewhere
along the line out in the middle of
Alaska somewhere pintron as we want to
call him basically just began building
this massive city and creating all these
Ultron robots now this does beg the
question what would have happened if you
launched an attack against the
superheroes in truth he probably would
have been unsuccessful Captain America
would have been banking on that or at
the very least he would have been
prepared for that because ultron has
been an enemy of the Avengers for so
long he would have just kind of adapted
to his own schemes and eventually
defeated Ultron but the idea here is
that Pym Tron's just kind of waiting in
the background and that's kind of a cool
scenario here because when they
initially show up and Iron Man's team
ends up fighting Captain America's Team
Ultron steps in and basically makes them
all stop now it's kind of a funny
scenario because we end up getting some
pretty interesting debates and also
answers to some questions that we've had
most notably what's going on with the
Scarlet Witch but one of the cool things
about the skull that which is character
historically speaking is that her mind
was always successful in keeping cthe
owned at bake-a-thon was just like this
wildly powerful demon that always wanted
to latch on to and use the
our of Wanda Maximoff for the idea was
that he was never really able to seize
total control of her now of course in
this circumstance by some means that's
never really explained to us Capone was
able to take over Scarlet Witch in ur
entirety now what do this was because of
the fact this Scarlet Witch had a
psychotic break when Captain America
first launched his strike whether it was
because of the fact that somebody messed
with her mind
we don't really know all we know is that
the demon cotone has taken over the
Scarlet Witch and that's why Wanda
Maximoff ended up siding with Captain
America the cool thing about this is
that Hank Pym begins to sort of address
these various issues that the teams have
and essentially saying they both believe
they're right they both believe they're
coming out on top of this they both
believe they're doing the right thing
but the question is who is actually
right here is a Captain America as a
Hydra agent who believes that he's
basically going to save the world by
effectively eradicating all the
superheroes in existence and if it goes
on long enough Hydra Captain America
will basically be ruling a cinder but at
the same time the superheroes really
kind of brought this on themselves and
that's the point that Hank Pym makes he
says look you guys have been fighting
forever you guys have been fighting for
so long the infighting it's always been
there it's always been a thing the only
difference here is that enemies came
fast and loose and so you always had
time to basically put your differences
aside and focus on those bad guys but
now you didn't have that opportunity now
one of the guys shows up and basically
proclaims themselves as being a villain
and all your chickens are coming home to
roost now the other cool thing about
this is that Tori Stark begins to goad
Hank Pym and this really hits to the
nature of its character because what he
basically ends up saying here is that
Hank Pym suffers from this constant
inferiority complex and he always did
that was the nature of his character he
stood alongside titans of the industry
like Tony Stark and his Iron Man armor
you had Thor he was basically a God who
had the Incredible Hulk who was a man
among gods
Captain America who everybody looked up
to there were always these superheroes
that everybody idolized or had some
insane amount of power for whatever
reason and then you had Hank Pym who
could shrink or grow and that was it
because of that it always instilled this
inferiority complex this combined with
the fact that Hank Pym created Ultron
and the fact that Hank Pym hit his wife
Tony Stark begins bringing all of these
up which in turn we thank him to
basically lash out now of course in this
moment this basically allows a sort of
Ultron and Hank
personalities to negotiate for lack of a
better word which allows Hank him to
essentially retake his mantle to kind of
get back to being normal more or less
but what is up happening here is that
when he sends everybody along their way
and when he ends up speaking with
Captain America one of the cool things
that happens here as he addresses the
nature of the end result of what will
happen remember with the character of
Ultron while Captain America could
likely defeat him it would be a long and
arduous journey and even then I may very
well have been kind of overshooting it a
little bit when I say the Captain
America could defeat Ultron because that
brings another question well what
happened in the age of Ultron event so
with regards to Captain America and with
regards to Ultron what he basically says
is even if the Ultron personality wanted
to conquer everything it wouldn't be who
him to do that it would actually make
the most sense to let them destroy each
other
this is really cool because what this
does is it hits home at a quote that
came from a movie called the sum of all
fears when it had this guy who was
basically a Nazi and he was trying to
find a way to take out the United States
and Russia and one of the things that he
said was that Adolf Hitler was stupid
that during the events of World War two
he said you don't fight the United
States and Russia that's crazy that's
suicide what you do is you get the
United States and Russia to fight each
other and destroy each other and that's
the beauty of Ultron's ultimate goal
here why fight Captain America and
Tony's start at the same time why fight
their enemies at the same time they're
going to fight until they're all dead
so why not just let them kill each other
and then conquer what's left
Napoleon Bonaparte did the exact same
thing I mean historically speaking when
it comes to any successful conquer
dictator Emperor or whatever the case
may be they all practice some pretty
keen key themes that are for the most
part unique Napoleon Bonaparte would go
into countries start civil wars wait
until their countries were at their
weakest and then conquer them that's how
he expanded his his empire so fast and
so again this really hits at the idea of
Captain America having effectively
obliterated the entirety or at least one
major temple of the Atlantis Kingdom
which resulted of course and namor the
sub-mariner handing over his piece of
the cosmic team again that was really
kind of like that little thread that was
effectively coming to a close but what
also ends up happening here is we get
this little piece of information we
basically find out that there's someone
on the inside of Iron Man's team there's
basically a mole this also picks up with
the idea of of Natasha Romanoff of Black
Widow now we don't see the full extent
of what it is that she's doing instead
what is up happening here is that
basically lead to the champions to
infiltrate a Hydra base but also the
idea that she basically picks up with a
villain named Viper
now Viper was a character who got her
claim to fame really is just one of the
notable enemies of various superhero
teams
she wasn't wasn't really like a great
big huge villain but she was one of
those who kind of hung out magic or
different things like that she had a
pretty cool role when it came to the
death of Wolverine but the idea here is
that it hits home at the notion that not
everybody who sides with Captain America
does so because they genuinely believe
in his cost Viper is an opportunist she
exists to make money that's her goal if
she can make cash off war profiteering
that's exactly what she will do and
what's happening here is that what Hydra
basically running the show she's running
a narcotics ring and it's kind of cool
because she's doing it under the scene
she's doing it without Captain America
knowing that his confident and of course
Natasha Romanoff says hey look despite
Captain America being a Hydra agent he
runs a pretty tight ship and if he finds
out that you're running narcotics he's
going to kill you he's going to use you
as an example he's going to string you
out there and that's going to be the end
of you and anybody who has the same
ideas but you have it so as one of these
cool little moments with these
characters we basically see these small
little tidbits coming out about the
things that are going on under the
surface now of course this also
coincides with Tony Stark traveling to
Lokhande what Conda received one of
these shards of the cosmic key when it
dispersed across the planet Earth the
difference here is that one of the Hydra
agents on a missoula who's really part
of the inner Council of Hydra has been
trying to infiltrate what Conda over and
over and over again fighting against
what Conda is not just walking into some
primitive African territory somewhere
and then just kicking it and then just
running off you're basically trying to
infiltrate the most technologically
advanced country in the world technology
that's well beyond anything that most of
the planet Earth actually has again what
is it happening here is this hits home
at the history of prior man and it's
kind of cool this exchange between the
two of them because initially Tony Stark
approaches black panther and says hey
give us your shard of the Cosmic Cube
and we will basically fix everything
now of course Black Panther response is
no we'll just basically wait it out and
of course 20 large responses well if you
do that a time will come when there will
be nothing for you to wade out what
eventually Captain America's forces
won't be held back you're facing against
what amounts to a garrison trying to
break into your place but what happens
if the full might of the Hydra army is
brought
on Wakanda are you really going to
sacrifice the entirety of your people
for the sake of a cosmic cube shard what
black panther basically responds by
saying is that every time Tony Stark
tried to do the right thing
he always screwed things up case in
point the original Civil War event and
that's the cool thing about this 20 suck
was like well hey look you know if
superheroes are fighting supervillains
it's only a matter of time before the
government gets tired of it and then
just mix all superhero activity illegal
in its entirety so I'm going to
basically support the passing of the
superhuman Registration Act and the hoax
that other superheroes will get on board
because it's for the greater good
instead what Tony Stark dead is
instigate one of the greatest political
social and superhero calamities in the
history of Earth and so again it's one
of these cool moments when it comes to
the history of twente Stark coming home
to roost and it hits home at the nature
that no one really trusts him now again
what this does is it follows up with the
rest of Tony Stark's team traveling to
all these different locations to these
different places for the purpose of
tracking down what they believe to be
these shards of the Cosmic Cube
explicitly because of the fact that Tony
Stark has this device supposedly that
tells them where the shards are at now
of course what we end up finding out
here is that this thing has been wrong
time and time again they've captured two
shards but they expected to find four or
five more but they haven't and the
question is why well no one really knows
the answer to this all they know is that
the device of Tony Stark isn't working
effectively now at this point we switch
over to probably one of the coolest
moments of the story which is basically
dealing with the x-men remember during
the whole secret Empire event the x-men
are out in Newton which is basically
this new land they've created for
themselves where no one bothers them now
in truth this is done for a couple of
reasons the first is because well you
know the mutant population isn't what it
was before the House of M so if they're
still reeling from the aftermath of that
the other half of this is that when it
comes to the mutant population they're
still pretty powerful mutants by and
large and Marvel Comics are consistently
the most powerful community of
characters in Marvel Comics and you have
a wide array of different abilities
planet-wide telepaths telekinetics you
have people like gambit who can charge
virtually anything he sees and blow it
up you've got Cyclops put optic beams
that can slice a mountain in half you've
got all these different characters and
all these different abilities but what
Captain America does here is he actually
plays it pretty smart and it's one of
the coolest quotes Hebrew
Hank McCoy over to where Thor's hammer
is at and the question is asked why
haven't you ever done anything with it
when Captain America's response is
whenever you went to these old kingdoms
and you would have these kings who had
had their swords above their throne it
wasn't to tell people yes I'm willing to
use it it's to tell people they did use
it and they used it to gain their empire
and that's basically what Captain
America does it's an intimidation
technique it basically brings Cape McCoy
over to the hammer of Thor and says hey
look I'm just a man but with the power
of four I can bring Newton to its knees
I can literally destroy everything that
you guys love and then you guys care
about and sure some of you guys might
take me out but in doing so and along
the way I will crush what little hope
you have left for restoring the mutant
population to what it used to be just
something to think about if you decide
you don't want to hand that shard of a
cosmic cube over to me that's one of the
cool things about this it's manipulative
cunning then when the question is asked
why it is that Odin's son even sided
with Captain America in the first place
what Odin's son does or at least what we
get is this cool explanation Odin's son
pays his allegiance to the hammer of
Thor he does not you know hold enemy
allegiance to Captain America but the
idea is that Captain America was worthy
of lifting the hammer and so because of
that odoo son effectively looks at this
and says if Captain America is able to
wield a hammer the hammer finds him
worthy if the hammer finds him worthy
then Who am I as unworthy Odin son to
stand in his way
now this is cool because what this does
is it feed doubt in the mind of Odin's
son it seems doubt in the mind of the
fact that he actually believes that what
Captain America is doing is right this
is really really important here and the
reason why is because remember Jane
Foster is out in some of the dimensions
somewhere it would not be that far
beyond the realm of possibility that
suddenly Odin's son gets back his
ability to wield a hammer and with the
power of four reigns he'll fire down on
Hydra and the reason why I say that the
reason why I say that kind of crazy
impossible scenario could be there is
because when we switch back over to Iron
Man we switch back over to the
conversations that he's having with
these other members of his own team when
the question is asked why isn't your
device working the response is given is
it never worked it was never designed to
work what does superheroes needed was
hope they needed to believe that the
thing would actually work and so what he
did is he basically analyzed and used
what little information they got from
Rick Jones at the begin
of the secret Empire story when rick
jones said well here's the best until we
have on where the shards may be and
basically began to kind of go through
all these swerves and all these turns to
make it look like the box was leading
them to where it was that they were
supposed to go only for to be revealed
that's not the case not only that we
actually end up finding out that the
person on the inside elisa seems to be
the person on the inside is mockingbird
that Mockingbird is the Hydra agent
spying on Tony Stark's team so again
this is huge because what it means is
that there are folks all over the place
there are people siding with all manner
of individuals against Tony Stark and
what is it happening is that in this
last little bit of a strike they
basically begin to assault the fortress
of the rebels what last little vestige
of hope they have left is rapidly
beginning to vanish and smoke and so
what we do as we get to this last little
bit of a cliffhanger is we join with
Captain America Bucky Barnes and Sam
Wilson as they're making their way again
through this vanishing point without us
knowing what it really is they basically
set upon by various traps that have been
set by some unknown man only for us to
find out that these traps that have been
set had been placed there by the Red
Skull who has every intention of
basically continuing its campaign to
kill Captain America but the true beauty
of this story the true little
cliffhanger here is that Captain America
begins to have this conversation again
with Arnim Zola and what they basically
reveal here is that this massive shield
you know this compound of the Avengers
can easily withstand this is salt from
Hydra and so what they need what they
need is a force of unrelenting fury they
need a force that can bust in that can
smash the place to pieces and that can
easily force all the different
superheroes out and so in the last tale
bit of this discussion we have Captain
America walk into a room and say Bruce
Banner it's good to see you again old
friend what happy side guy we're going
to go ahead and bring this video to an
end if you are new here two comments
explained make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the Rob gore if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later hey
[Music]